we've got some breaking news now and
coronavirus cases have risen again in
the uk up 27
since last week joining me now is our
correspondent ashish joshi
up 27 percent that doesn't sound very
good
no it doesn't sound very good
but the trend has been upwards for the
last couple of weeks let me break that
27 percent down
for us kimberly that is
471 000 people amounting to
2.2 million people across the uk had
coronavirus week ending the 24th of june
now this
rising cases has been driven by variance
ba 0.4 and ba 0.5 as it has been for the
last few weeks if we break those figures
down across
all four regions they're up in all four
regions 1.8 million people in england
that's one in 30 106 000 in wales that
is also one in 30 people with the
infection
71 000 people in northern ireland that's
one in 25
288 000 in scotland
that amounts to 1 in 18 people
the figures themselves will make more
sense when you you look at the impact
they're having firstly on the national
health service and secondly on employers
who are struggling to deliver goods and
services we've seen the cues at airports
and we know what's happening
to
people who are having to take time off
sick
luckily school will be breaking up quite
soon because that's having an impact on
the number of children who are being
infected too
the infections are rising not only
across all four regions but the uk hsa
said yesterday that hospitalizations are
up
outbreaks in care homes are up and
crucially
intensive care unit admissions in older
age groups are also going up so the
pressure beginning the pressure exists
already on the nhs we know that but
certainly the coveted 19 pressure
beginning to creep up quite
significantly um in all four regions and
we'll just have to see what sort of
impact it's going to have across the
rest of the summer
okay ashish thank you very much